How much do you really know about the elusive
natasha romanov before i worked for shield
i made a name for myself when it
was time to assemble the avengers
who did shield call let me put you on hold
former kgb assassin agent of shield and avenger
she fought through the battle of new york squared
off against the winter soldier defended the world
against ultron she signed the sokovia accords
dealt with all that fallout and
beat back the forces of thanos
when all seemed lost she
held the team together but
how well do you really know her it's time
for her story i've lived a lot of lives
you've been waiting for this you don't know
everything about me i've lived a lot of lives
before i was an avenger
before i got this family i made mistakes
choosing between what the world wants you to be
and who you are
we have to go back to where it all started
where did you think i was all this
time we have unfinished business
my girls are the toughest
girls in the world i'm sorry
we had our orders and we
played our role it wasn't real
it was real to me
to me you were everything
Bring her home
one thing's for sure i'm
done running from my past
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
black widow trailer video they just dropped a new
trailer for the movie for superhero day obviously
there's a couple more easter eggs in here and we
learned about some really big connections to what
happened during falcon and winter soldier in the
post-credits scenes so i'll explain what's going
on with that if you're brand new to the channel
i'll be doing videos for all the marvel disney
plus and all the movie stuff this year so be sure
to subscribe to get those episodes the loki series
is actually going to overlap with the black widow
movie when they drop it in theaters and on disney
plus at the same time you will be able to watch it
on disney plus starting in july but the big thing
that they're hyping up in this trailer is just all
the flashbacks to her during the 90s when she was
a kid growing up and then joining the black widow
program and what happened during that timeline
the black widow movie takes place during a couple
different time periods like obviously talking
about the flashbacks here to her as a little girl
in america pretending to be an american family
while they were on this mission but most of the
plot will take place between captain america
civil war before avengers infinity war that's
why she doesn't have the blonde hair that she has
when she shows up at the beginning of infinity war
then because of some of the new information and
the connections to falcon and winter soldier
plot it sounds like some of the movie will take
place in actual present day after the end of
avengers end game so i'll actually explain that
first just because it's really cool we just saw
the falcon and winter soldier episodes some
new characters showed up during that implied
some big future for thunderbolts and dark avengers
stuff so the big news is that the director of the
falcon and winter soldier episodes confirmed that
julia louis-dreyfus's val character madame hydra
was originally supposed to debut during the
black widow movie at least that was the place
we were supposed to meet her first so i think
the idea was is she was always going to show up
on falcon and winter soldier and even though the
black widow movie was delayed till after falcon
and winter soldier they didn't really change her
storyline that much so theoretically she's still
doing the same thing that she was always going
to be doing during the black widow film when she
shows up during that the way they talked about her
on falcon and winter soldier is they designed her
to be a dark version of nick fury so i'm assuming
that that same metaphor holds for what she's doing
during the black widow film what is nick fury
most known for assembling the avengers what is the
dark version of the avengers literally the dark
avengers but also kind of the thunderbolts too
there are a couple big characters during the
black widow movie that would make amazing
thunderbolts or dark avengers characters because
you have yelana belova basically taking the mantle
of black widow in the mcu from natasha black
widow even though the funny thing about that
is that they're all black widows like the red room
program the black widow program trains many black
widows is that when we talk about natasha we refer
to her as the black widow scarlett johansson did
confirm last year during interviews that the movie
was meant to be sort of a passing of the baton of
the mantle of black widow so at the end of falcon
and winter soldier during those end credit scenes
we saw her basically turn john walker meant him
as the new us agent of the mcu basically just the
comic book turn we always thought that he was
going to become u.s asian but he gets the full
costume hopefully when he shows up again in a new
project we'll see him with the us agent version
of the shield too he has a shield that looks just
like captain america shield it's just painted to
look like u.s agents colors the only difference
is that it's not vibranium like captain america
shield but it's also way better than the home
depot version of the homemade shield that he made
during episode 5. but the way the val character
talked her dialogue made it sound like they
were going to be doing really shady stuff she
would be having them do really shady missions
and she referred to zemo as if he were a
friend like our friend zemo got the last laugh
so she's a character that wields great power
and is associated with the us government
and she's putting together a darker team of
anti-heroes so the early theory is that she's
doing similar things during the black widow movie
so regardless of where she shows up during that in
what part of the timeline whether it's during
the period between captain america civil war
in avengers infinity war or if she shows up in
a post-credits scene after the end of avengers
endgame and present day the theory is that if it's
not going to be thunderbolt ross that's putting
together thunderbolts and dark avengers characters
she would be the actual person to physically go
meet with people like taskmaster and yelandabalova
to offer them a chance to pay off some of their
sentences the same way she went to john walker
after he basically got drummed out of the military
like look you're a super soldier this is the best
thing that you could have done to yourself taking
that serum there are a lot of people that would
find that very useful and attractive i think the
big difference though with her character and all
this thunderbolts dark avengers setup is that we
know that thunderbolt ross is a character in the
black widow movie because we've seen him in the
trailer before we saw the falcon of winter soldier
episodes there was a theory that thunderbolt ross
was associated with a lot of the darker stuff that
was happening in the series that's still possible
even though he didn't actually have a cameo scene
during the series kevin feige did say that they
re-engineered some of the connections between the
marvel phase four projects because of the way they
shuffled the order of some of the movies in the
disney plus series but he said for the most part
the overarching story that they had always planned
is the same i think the idea is they just edited a
couple of post credit scenes here and there just
so that everything makes sense and you're seeing
things in the right order but i guess for whatever
reason seeing val show up during falcon and winter
soldier doesn't break the timeline when we see
her potentially show up during the black widow
film it's just that when you would see her in the
black widow film it won't be as big of a surprise
as if you were seeing her for the first time
like oh we know exactly what she's here for so
pretty safe bet that they wind up not killing off
the taskmaster character just too big of a marvel
anti-hero character they could bring back anybody
who's just a super badass is just in marvel's best
interest to find a way to explain how they survive
the events of whatever movie they show up in
they kind of ran into that problem with the
killmonger character even though talking about
black panther too michael b jordan said that
he would love to come back as that character
so obviously they'd have to have some huge twist
to explain because supposedly he died at the end
of the black panther film but if you guys didn't
know killmonger actually is a big character during
the marvel what if series which is actually
going to be releasing after the loki series
so i'll talk more about the what if series later
this summer when we start getting more trailers
for that because it's a little bit different from
the normal marvel disney plus series in the movies
it's more of an else world series that sort of
combines a lot of events of alternate universes
like what if events had played out differently so
you have vastly different versions of all the main
mcu characters but all the actors are coming back
to do the voices for their characters that's the
reason why they're doing it after the loki's
series though is because it relies heavily on
the idea of the multiverse trope but the other big
reveal from this new trailer is drakov's character
so remember that scene from the first avengers
movie where loki is sort of taunting black widow
calling her drakov's daughter making references
to all these terrible things the red on her ledger
the people that she'd killed on her missions when
he's whispering in the ear of taskmaster here
saying bring her home i actually think now that
he's talking about the yelena belova black widow
like at some point you have the events of budapest
that's where black widow natasha meets hawkeye
and then eventually defects and starts working for
shield and nick fury i think the idea is that when
that happened she effectively left her sister
so to speak yelena belova black widow behind
so she's actually going back to budapest here in
present day or at least after the events of civil
war to save her so it's not so much taskmaster
going after natasha black widow during all these
scenes when he's chasing them down trying to kill
them or it seems like he's trying to kill them he
might just be trying to capture yelana belova
black widow and bring her back into the program
for the most part natasha's storyline during the
film is just learning that the red room is still
very much active the black widow program
and she wants to destroy it completely
so that they can't induct and brainwash any other
women i think the idea with drakov's character
though is that he's sort of like this russian
general kgb character who's orchestrating events
from behind the scenes with the red room any sort
of this darker spin on a father figure for natasha
and yelena belova black widow and you have david
harbor's character who's sort of the good father
figure to her that she remembers he's playing red
guardian alexis shostakov in the comics he's kind
of like the russian version of captain america who
gets a version of the super soldier serum as well
that's how he's able to go toe-to-toe with
taskmaster here so even though taskmaster does
have the ability to copy everyone else's moves
i'm also kind of wondering if they're going to
give taskmaster a version of the super soldier
serum during the black widow film but if you
spotted any of the big easter eggs in the trailer
that i didn't talk about in the video or you have
any big questions about what's going on with the
black widow film and how it's connected to the
other marvel phase 4 films just let me know in
the comments like i said it does seem like the
val character is the key to future marvel phase
4 storyline pushing that forward even though the
black widow film mostly takes place in the past
everyone click here for my full falcon winter
soldier episode 6 finale video and click here
for that official captain america 4 marvel movies
announcement video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!